monster Big Time wind by Andy Ruiz jr. /
Anthony Joshua and his latest column in
Sports Illustrated is all about it
shades of Buster Andy Ruiz shocks the
world with upset of Anthony Joshua Chris
Maddox here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Chris
got red side done what was it like to
see this it was wild you know I had one
of my first you know broadcasting you
know eat your words moment I was I was
sitting there and you know I see Joshua
fight said I think he's a terrific
finisher so when he put her ease down
and I'm sure you can relate to this I
said you know Anthony Joshua is a
composed and ferocious finisher watch
this and then he got knocked down so you
know not my not my finest moment as a
broadcaster but certainly I mean you
mentioned Buster Douglas and I wrote
about that little bit Buster Douglas
Tyson Lennox Lewis Aseem Rahman these
are kind of moments that you remember
not necessarily where you were but you
know how they unfolded and this is one
of those moments we're all going to
remember this as one of the great upsets
in boxing history
well so how did he do it Chris I know
that he's he's obviously an unknown a
relative unknown who's known for sucking
his gut and during the during the way
and more than anything else before this
fight who is this guy well I mean there
are some scorchingly hot bat takes
coming in about what Andy Ruiz is I know
he's not he's not butter bean he's not
you know just some you know club fighter
and this is a guy that top ranked Bob
Arum invested a lot of time and money in
early in his career he had a great
amateur record and the only loss on his
Pro resume was to Joseph Parker and I
was in a heavyweight championship fight
and he lost by the skin of his teeth so
he came in as a pretty accomplished guy
all that being said he was a heavy
underdog for a reason because he'd never
fought a fighter that had the power that
Anthony Joshua had that's why when he
was put in the deck so many people
myself included
obviously thought Joshua was going to go
in for for the finish and Andrew we
showed something he had never shown
never had to show in his professional
career and ability to take a big shot
recover and give a big shot back there's
certainly our questions about Anthony
Joshua's chin after something like this
I think first and foremost it's about
anterior ITA's heart and these ability
to recover from a knockdown well and
Chris Mannix here in the Rich Eisen show
it's it's not look it's far be it for me
to question anybody's heart to certainly
since you know you just put on the
gloves and and that takes heart to begin
with all that said it was kind of
bizarre how Anthony Joshua didn't like
completely flip out after he was counted
out and then was seen smiling taking
pictures with the guy who just beat him
did you find his post loss reaction odd
Chris I found it odd not as odd as maybe
the casual observer of Anthony Joshua
would he's just kind of a very aloof guy
and a very he doesn't kind of fit the
mike tyson mold of this assassin or even
Lennox Lewis or Vladimir Klitschko he
just never had fit that mold and the
build-up to to the fight at the press
conference Joshua Ruiz try on his belts
like put them on his shoulder and take
pictures with them I hadn't seen that
happen before you know in in boxing it
just kind of fits his personality the
other part of it is you know and I've
learned this in the last 48 hours
he was pretty badly concussed after that
like he did the shots he took they left
him worse for wear so any kind of you
know days that he might have been in and
and and whatever his personality was I
think the fact they took such a pretty
savage beating that's something to do
with it
Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated here
on the Rich Eisen show so just today
Joshua already with Ruiz they they're
they're gonna do it again right they
they already yeah cashed in the rematch
that happened yeah and he heard the
promoter just announced maybe half an
hour ago that they were triggering the
rematch clause that'll be before the end
of the year over in the UK over in the
UK
okay this is yeah alright so what does
this mean are we are we back here is the
heavyweight division back I mean the
disown get in just at the right time I
mean it because it kind of seems like
we're talking about a lot more here
Chris it it did a hundred percent does I
mean it it ever is you know in the
aftermath
you know people wonder was this bad for
the zone they invested and Anthony
Joshua and I don't want to seem like a
company still here but immediately
afterwards I my first reaction was great
for the zone this is what this is what
everyone was talking about the YouTube
clips of this review tens of millions of
times like all over social media
and all of our mainstream networks
you're seeing highlights of this fight
with the zone branding I mean a big
problem I thought the zone had and I
guess has to a degree is that the
awareness factor they're trying to make
people aware what they are and how they
you can consume fight through them most
people it like box you're now aware of
it and if this fight had gone according
to plan if Anthony Joshua had knocked
out Ruiz in the third round
Joshua would have gone on to fight a
mandatory title defense against a guy
named Cooper I pool of some time in the
fall and nobody would have watched now
even if it's an afternoon fight in the
UK or in the US rather you're going to
see a lot of people invested in and
dying to see the rematch between Joshua
and Ruiz this is a I think it's a great
thing for heavyweight boxing and to a
lesser degree a great thing for dessert
and then Ruiz we all have heard about
his Mexican heritage is he's a
descendant of of those from Mexico but
he's from the Imperial Valley here in
Southern California
I mean so what does this mean for
American fighters the American
heavyweight game Chris I I think it's
great I mean I think look if Andy Ruiz
ghost you King it's knocked out by by by
Joshua which is distinctly possible I
mean if he goes over there and gets beat
I don't know how big a player he's going
to be able to remain on the national
stage but certainly he's put himself in
position to be a really viable contender
over the next year plus and if he can
duplicate what he did against Joshua all
of a sudden you have an extremely
makeable fight between Amy Ruiz and
Deontay Wilder
but the undisputed heavyweight
championship that's that's a fight
that's going to resonate with everybody
even the most casual of fans of boxing
so Andy Ruiz he's gonna have to do it
again
but if he can in front of 80,000 fans in
the UK he's gonna make himself a big
star put another American figure on that
world stage and I got Tyson Fury in
studio tomorrow Chris what do you think
is the most important thing to ask of
him here is is pure entertainment I just
want to know you know like he he's gonna
fight Deontay Wilder in that rematch in
in in February that's a huge fight in
boxing I'd like to know how he's gonna
fight the ante while there again I mean
he had a great game plan throughout that
first fight but he took a savage
knockdown I'm wondering if he's the same
fighter after taking that knock gun he
got up but I've seen a lot of times rich
where guys have taken big punch than
Deontay Wilder believes this that
they're not the same after shots like
that so I'm wondering if Tyson tier is
gonna be better in the rematch or if
he's going to be a step slower in the
rematch the Chris Mannix here and the
Rich Eisen show just switching gears in
the few minutes I have left with you
here the knockdown in Game two by the
Warriors to the Raptors do you think
that that is something the Raptors can
get up from or are the Warriors so
battered that this is still a series for
the Raptors to take Chris where do you
stand on this subject
I think the Raptors Delta feel pretty
good about their chances of falling off
this upset I mean losing Game two is
tough but their star is the most I don't
know what the phrase is singularly
focused ambivalent to everything that
goes on around him he's it's all about
basketball and all about winning and
he's been in tougher situations as a
member of the Spurs that being Kawhi
Leonard so I think he's gonna play
extremely well against Golden State I
think he's he's gonna be great and you
know the Raptors have shown some mental
toughness throughout these playoffs now
it's a bigger stage no question but
being down to zip two to Milwaukee and
that series and coming back Fred
vanvleet started that series playing
terribly and finished it playing great
you know you listen to what the Raptors
said in the locker room after that game
you know they know that they they caused
all the
like they they miss shot and maybe shots
that usually make in that third quarter
I think that have confidence throw in
the fact that this is like a mass unit
over there with Golden State
Durant's not going to play Kevin Looney
is out and I got klay Thompson is
questionable but klay Thompson that's a
bad hamstring injury any kind of smart
coach is going to go at him and make him
prove he can be out there on the floor
defensively so I'm I'm skeptical that
they're gonna be able to get a lot out
of klay Thompson in that game three so
that's a long way of saying that this
this series is still very much in
Toronto's and Toronto's way well still
the only video we see if Durant is in
the tunnel in Toronto barking at Aubrey
who he and klay Thompson were we're
barking a Drake what when we see Durant
do we see him at all do you think yeah
it just like in most postseason series
everyone plays this close to the best I
mean I have heard from from people that
know him that he's going to be back
during this series nobody's willing to
say what game or when what you have to
watch rich is the practice if he's out
there in the floor right now he is
practicing in a very very limited way
before he can go out and play big
minutes in an NBA game he's got to go
through a full-bore practice and until
he does that I'm not gonna think about
Kevin Durant coming back any idea why
he's not watching from the bench Chris I
don't know some guys don't do it some
guys do some guys don't I mean I
remember Kevin Garnett when he was
injured throughout the years never watch
games from the bench I don't you know
think too much and I'm I'm glad he was
there if he had not traveled with the
team to Toronto I would have thought
something might be up but the fact that
he's there I don't read too much more
into it alright I know you got 90
seconds left here so I'll throw in front
of you the the supposition from Bill
plashy out here in LA that if the Lakers
with LeBron would either one out or get
out or the Lakers would give them an
exit visa
Kyrie coming here would obviously take
that off the table what do you get what
are your thoughts on that subject
right now
yeah I mean I think if they do with
infer agency and maybe more importantly
they whiff on the trade market because
I've long believed that that was their
most realistic path to getting a better
player I mean we all look at Anthony
Davis but Bradley Beal is someone I
think could be more realistic
once Washington settles on a general
manager they're going to want to start
clearing some salary to rebuild and
Beale is is pricey but he's been proven
he's worth the money over the years I
think the wages would be interested in
in some of the pieces the Lakers have to
offer but if they whip on everything and
they go into training camp with largely
the same group
I think they'd approach LeBron about out
because from the Lakers perspective
you've got to think that if the bran
goes we're not in a terrible position
our contracts are bad we've got young
talent we go back to trying to grow in a
more organic way obviously want to keep
LeBron around and build around him with
other stars but it might be mutually
beneficial to part ways if you don't get
get things done through the month of
August but I think they'll stretch it
out rich I think we'll be into September
October start a training camp before any
kind of conversation like that takes
place because you're still going to see
guys and some movement I think deep it
to the summer Chris thanks for the call
we'll chat before the draft if not
before that hey Cameron you gotta ask
Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated
joiners here for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app